à
[Musique]
massimo groupes mondiaux mesdames c'est
un énorme plaisir pour moi d'être avec
vous ce matin ce toqué chiffre modeste
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment un plaisir
pour moi de voir dans cette salle autant
de jeunes qui vont écouter du crack et
se partage d'expérience c'est
extrêmement important et les publics est
extrêmement adéquat pour pouvoir écouter
ces messages et partage avec lequel il
partage et demi ça y est je suis daouda
mougnan je suis responsable de bookeen
by international book inn by savez dit
normal en jeunes intègrent jeunes
introduit jeunes travailleurs et pour
qu'une bille est un bureau d'études qui
est spécialisé si les questions de
développement des adolescents et des
jeunes
je souhaiterais parler des adolescents
et des jeunes comme facteurs comme
moteur de développement de mon pays le
pays des hommes intègres le burkina faso
il est très sûr que les concepts le nord
du pays évoque un certain nombre de
choses
les bouquins faso c'est aussi thomas
sankara le burkina faso avec sa capitale
est la capitale du cinéma africain le
festival panafricain du cinéma et de la
télévision de ouagadougou
pourquoi donc parler des adolescents et
des jeunes
vous allez me dis vraiment quel est
l'intérêt je crois comme je vais vous
parler des adolescents et des jeunes au
burkina parce que c'est la frange
majoritaire au burkina faso
deux personnes une personne site e au
burkina faso à un âge compris entre 10
et 35 ans
je vais vous parler des adolescents et
des jeunes parce que c'est la population
majorité qui travaille au burkina 60%
des 16 35 ans forment la population
active du burkina faso je vais enfin
vous parlez des adolescents et des
jeunes parce que pour le burkina faso
et comme pour l'ensemble du continent
les jeunes constituent notre avenir et
pour ce faire
quand vous arrivez chez nous vous avez
énormément du programme et nos mondes
projet énormément de fonds qui sont
destinés à promouvoir les jeunes
cependant je crois que ce que j'avais
dit
c'est pour peut-être interpeller pour
moi les génies ne sont pas l'avenir
pas du tout les jeunes c'est notre
présent ils sont notre présence
cependant nous avions développé un
certain nombre de programmes se basant
sur le fait qu'ils sont notre avenir et
ses programmes n'ont pas mâché
à titre d'exemple l'ensemble des fonds
l'ensemble des programmes qui sont
publics et des projets publics au
burkina n'a lui pas à régler les
questions fondamentales qui sont
l'emploi et l'employabilité des séries
en termes d'emploi tous ces fonds ne
crée que 6000 emplois par an au bout
quillan pour une demande qui est estimé
à un million vous voyez on ne peut pas
faire les ratios tellement c'est
difficile je crois aussi
et pendant longtemps pour avoir
travaillé dans les institutions
internationales s'occupant
spécifiquement des jeunes étant au coeur
même comme on dit de la planification
dans ces organisations nous avions
développé un certain nombre de
programmes pour les jeunes et on s'est
rendu compte que ces programmes là
restent timides précise et donc il est
extrêmement important et ça nous amène à
se poser de nombreuses questions
ça m'a amené à se dire est ce que je
suis efficace
là où je suis
où il sert et efficace si je suis avec
les chaînes qui tient avec les chiens il
discute avec les chiens c'est dans cet
esprit que j'ai créée juste après mon
départ de l'unicef book inn by
internationale pour nous était convaincu
que les jeunes sont le présent la
création de ce bureau doit compter biais
apaisé baiser qu'elle ou si les
programmes des chaînes faire en sorte
que ça ne soit pas une priorité
c'est pour que ça soit la priorité c'est
pourquoi pour ne pas faire comme on les
fait une amende à 7 dans toutes ses
décisions dans tous ces organismes pour
né pas avoir la colère des jeunes et des
adolescents en pomme vous l'avez vu en
2014 en octobre qui n'a faso c'est
pourquoi français dit pour ne pas avoir
ces collets cette colère il est
extrêmement important pour nous de nous
coller aux besoins
et aux aspirations des jeunes pour ce
faire nous sommes dit qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire il faut commencer quelque
part et c'est quelque part il fallait
fait un état des lieux exhaustif
c'est là une analyse de la situation
comme on les dit de l'emploi de
l'employabilité déchire la formation
professionnelle et de l'utilisation de
tous ces faux pour avoir une vue
d'ensemble et bâtir sur ça pour fait des
suggestions et mettre en place des
programmes tesquet nous on a mis en
place s est un homme d'action et nous
sommes aussi en train de continuer de
les mettre en place
la première d'entre elles c'est le
centre polyvalent agro sylvo pastorale
qui va permettre à un certain nombre
d'adolescents et de jeunes en milieu
rural d'acquérir des compétences dans
ces trois domaines mais aussi le
développement et la chaîne des valeurs
relatives à ces domaines nous sommes dit
qu'il n'est pas on a constaté la
question de l'employabilité qui est
assez faible
nous sommes impliqués pour résoudre
cette question
en plus de la formation professionnelle
nous allons placer les jeunes en
entreprise de sorte que les jeunes
apprenants à la fin de l'information au
lieu qu'on leur demande est-ce que vous
avez une expérience il soit déjà
compétents et ça tu crois que c'est un
élément extrêmement essentiel
pour les jeunes au burkina faso
notamment les jeunes qui vivent en
milieu rural
parce qu ils sont 75% des jeunes qui y
vivent et qui n'ont ils ne savent ni
lire ni écrire souvent nous pensons
aussi qu'il est extrêmement important de
booth des d'encourager de faire en sorte
que ceux qui sont susceptibles de créer
de l'emploi puisse le faire donc on a
institué le plus beau qu'une bille du
meilleur employé des jeunes qui se passe
chaque année pour permettre non
seulement de récompenser ceux qui sont
les camps pouvoir d'emplois pour les
jeunes et des formations mais aussi de
faire un plaidoyer au niveau du
gouvernement pour qu on essaie de voir
comment on peut alléger ce qu'ils font
et l'état pourquoi les pme encore ne
touchait plus deuxième parce qu'ils n'en
avons beaucoup qui ne savaient pas
l'autre élément qui est aussi important
à nos yeux c'est la révolution de
l'éducation et de la formation
professionnelle je crois qu est
aujourd'hui si nous voulons nous en
sortir
il est extrêmement important que nos
jeunes soient dotés de capacités et des
compétences qu'ils soient employables
des sorte qu' il puisse par eux-mêmes où
en est en en étant d'aller d'entreprise
être plus efficace ce que vous ne savez
pas ce que ne savait pas c'est que nous
avons un continent extrêmement jeunes
eux ce n'est pas ça seulement en 2050
un jeune sur deux dans le monde entier
c'est là africain et si nos jeunes ne
sont pas compétents s'ils ne sont pas
forts il ne pense pas que nous pourrions
relever le défi du développement du
continent africain
c'est pour cela en terminant je visitais
cette expression les jeunes vous n'êtes
pas l'avenir si on dit que vous êtes
l'avenir on va reléguer au second plan
vos préoccupations
vous êtes le présent et ce qui est
encore plus important
je crois que dans notre pays nous on l'a
aperçu plus rien n'est fait là encore
sans les jeunes nous n'allons pas réussi
sans les chiens les jeunes vous êtes
notre présent vous êtes notre présent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]